if you're an addict of any kind
moderation never works I think it was in
the 17th century the 18th century there
was a saint named Saint Augustine who
said abstinence is easier than perfect
moderation and if people could
understand that it moderation for really
rarely works for anyone but it's never
worked for an addict and it that is the
hardest concept Rich for people to grasp
is the concept of abstinence one of my
first clients and their their struggle
was cheese actually which is also
another addictive substance it's an
animal product a processed food a
casomorphines opiate in the brain kind
of thing and they say well I can't do
this and I'm like well why they go well
I can't be expected to go to France and
not eat the cheese right it's just a
story no but then I said well when are
you going to France and they go well I'm
not I go when have you ever been to
France they go I have it if I ever have
time to write another book it'll be
about some of the excuses that I hear
why people can't do this because that's
what addicts do they make excuses and
you know you can't have both excuses and
results at the same time